[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show".
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Firebase Dynamic
Links are deep links
that drive user
growth and engagement
by allowing you to send users
to specific places in your app,
across iOS, Android,
and the web.
And now you can customize your
dynamic links in three ways--
a brand-agnostic domain, custom
subdomains, and custom paths.
Take a look at the
post to get started.
You can now deploy your Node.js
8 applications to App Engine
standard environment.
This support brings
a number of benefits,
including fast deployments
and automatic scaling,
idiomatic developer experience,
and strong security.
Get started with the links
and the video on the post.
Cloud Dataflow Streaming Engine
moves pipeline execution out
of the worker VMs and into the
Cloud Dataflow service backend.
And it is now available in beta.
This leads to
several improvements,
which are detailed on the post.
Partner Interconnect lets you
connect your on-prem resources
to Google Cloud Platform
from the partner
location of your
choice at a data
rate that meets your needs.
And now, it's
generally available,
which means you can now receive
an SLA for Partner Interconnect
connections if you use one of
the recommended topologies.
For information on choosing
a partner, bandwidth options,
and pricing, head
on over to the post.
Our 16th Google Cloud Platform
region, located in Finland,
is now open for you to
build applications and store
your data.
For more about the data
center and which services
are available, take a
look at the post, linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show".
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
[LAUGHS]
OK.
SPEAKER 1: At least
you don't have a cat.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I got a dog.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, but
not super long hair.